[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
DAVID DUCHOVNY:
Thanks for coming out.
We'll do a couple songs.
And then we'll talk, and then
we'll do a couple more songs,
and then we'll get
the fuck out of here.
[LAUGHTER]
[MUSIC - DAVID DUCHOVNY, "HALF
LIFE"]
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
I want to say something so I can
scroll the fuck out of there.
[LAUGHTER]
If I say something--
I said it again, so
now I got to look at--
SPEAKER 1: I'm stuck.
DAVID DUCHOVNY: I've got to
stop saying fuck, so that--
oh, shit.
Now I'm-- this is bad.
All right.
Oh.
OK, we'll do another song now.
We'll do the-- we'll do
"Every Third Thought?"
"Every Third Thought."
[MUSIC - DAVID DUCHOVNY, "EVERY
THIRD THOUGHT"]
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
Real good-- my mother
would be OK with that.
[LAUGHS] We'll do
one more, and then
we'll do a little chatting?
Yeah, OK, cool.
Uh, what you want to do?
SPEAKER 1: Little "Highwater"?
DAVID DUCHOVNY: "Hell
or Highwater," OK.
We'll do "Hell or Highwater."
[MUSIC - DAVID DUCHOVNY, "HELL
OR HIGHWATER"]
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
[INAUDIBLE]
SPEAKER 2: Hello.
DAVID DUCHOVNY: Hi.
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKER 2: So first
off, thanks for coming.
DAVID DUCHOVNY:
Thanks for having me.
SPEAKER 2: We appreciate it.
I want to start with, like,
some broader questions.
And then sort of work my way
down to more specific stuff
about you work.
DAVID DUCHOVNY: I
like your strategy.
SPEAKER 2: Thank you.
So first question is, like,
in tech, so we have this--
DAVID DUCHOVNY: Tech?
You lost me.
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKER 2: We have a huge--
one of our buzzwords
is pivoting.
DAVID DUCHOVNY: Uh oh.
SPEAKER 2: And, you know,
you've done academia.
You know, you went to Princeton
and Yale, all but dissertation.
You've, you know, movies,
TV shows, "X-Files,"
"Californication,"
and now music.
So I guess my question for
you is, you seem to have--
DAVID DUCHOVNY: Novels.
I've got a third novel coming--
SPEAKER 2: You
write novels, too.
DAVID DUCHOVNY:
I don't want to--
I pivot.
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKER 2: Novels, too--
I wanted to ask more
about that later as well.
I read "Bucky Fucking Dent."
DAVID DUCHOVNY: You did?
SPEAKER 2: Yeah, I did.
So--
DAVID DUCHOVNY: That's
it, is you've read it?
Are you going to say
anything about it?
SPEAKER 2: No, I'll be
giving compliments later on.
DAVID DUCHOVNY: Oh!
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKER 2: So you seem to have--
DAVID DUCHOVNY: I don't
like that strategy.
I like the strategy--
compliments off the top.
But anyway, go ahead.
SPEAKER 2: OK.
So you seem to have pivoted
a lot, successfully,
in your career.
So how are you able to do it?
What sort of challenges
did you face?
DAVID DUCHOVNY: Oh,
well, I mean, it--
I just think it's not that
I get bored so easily.
I just think I have looked
for other modes of expression
to convey whatever it is I
feel I was put here to convey,
so just finding different
ways of expressing whatever
it is on my mind or
my heart at the time.
So I started out as a
writer, unpublished,
and then I became an actor.
And then I went back to
being a writer, actor,
and then I discovered music
and started writing, you know,
lyrically that way and also
rediscovered myself as a prose
writer at the same time.
So I don't know.
It wasn't really intentional.
It's more just,
like, I don't know
how to phrase it in a way
that makes total sense.
But it's just like looking for
another window out or window
open to communicate something
through that open window.
I've lost it now.
But I think-- but
your question, you
know, it afforded me
a lot of opportunity.
Because I had notoriety
as an actor to be given
a listen as a musician
or a read as a novelist.
At the same time,
though, you know,
I'm open to attacks of
just being a dilettante.
So it's both.
I get an opportunity to reach
more people than I probably
would if I didn't have
any kind of notoriety.
But also I don't
get taken seriously.
Like, what the
fuck are you doing?
You know?
Why don't you just
stay in your own lane?
SPEAKER 2: Is your Twitter
tagline still dilettante?
DAVID DUCHOVNY: No,
but that's good.
It was.
When I used to actually
involve myself in it.
SPEAKER 2: Yeah, when I first
followed you it was dilletante.
I really like that tagline.
DAVID DUCHOVNY:
I'll bring it back.
Brad?
Dilletante.
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKER 2: Yeah, so
I guess my second--
I think, from a lot of
your writing-- like I said,
I read "Bucky Fucking Dent."
I really enjoyed it.
You can talk more
about it if you want.
It's David's second novel.
So the main character
lives in the Bronx.
Much of it-- it's, like,
all set in New York.
In "Hell or Highwater,"
a lot of your songs
also reference New
York, your first album.
DAVID DUCHOVNY: I know.
I know.
SPEAKER 2: So what are your
favorite New York haunts?
DAVID DUCHOVNY:
What's my problem?
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKER 2: Where can we find
you on a random Tuesday night?
DAVID DUCHOVNY: Home.
[LAUGHTER]
I grew up in New York.
So it's in me just as
a reference, you know?
It has all this feeling for me.
And I don't say that
I love New York.
I'm not one of those guys.
I kind of love-hate
it, with the emphasis
on hate a lot of the time.
So I find myself just writing
about it in a weird way.
As much as I always
talk about leaving it,
I feel like I'm destined to
never leave it in some way.
Even though I think I've
been trying to leave it
for most of my adult life.
So I think that's kind of the
push-pull with me and New York.
I mean, I grew up
not far from here.
I grew up, I told you, 11th
Street and Second Avenue.
SPEAKER 2: Yeah.
DAVID DUCHOVNY: And it's
all very different now.
But you know, this is
my favorite neighborhood
of New York, the East
Village and the West Village.
To me, that really has
a lot of nostalgia.
Because I used to hang out.
I did hang out here.
There was a movie theater
where The Equinox is
now, which tells
you everything you
need to know about New
York, on Greenwich and 12th,
I think it is.
SPEAKER 2: OK.
So I think I want
to get a little more
into your current album.
I know that some of your
songs, I think, "Spiral"
was written by your bandmates.
"Marble Sun" was kind of
a collaborative effort.
I assume, you know,
the rest is solo.
Do you prefer--
DAVID DUCHOVNY: Well,
not really solo--
but the other ones
would have been songs
that I first wrote on my own
and then brought to the guys
and we worked on them.
So, yeah, I guess the
inspiration would be solo.
And then the actual
execution of them
would be more of a team effort.
SPEAKER 2: I see.
Do you prefer like
one over the other?
DAVID DUCHOVNY: I'm
just not good enough
to really bring it home myself.
I mean, I'm not--
I'm not, like, a
schooled musician.
And I throw chords together
and put words and melodies
on those chords.
And then, you know, when
we first started working--
and I will introduce you to the
guys when they come back up,
if they haven't left
already-- have they left?
You know, I was, like-- they
were, like, oh, this song needs
a bridge.
And I'm, like, well,
what's a bridge?
[LAUGHTER]
So an architectural question
I didn't understand.
So it's been a learning
process for me,
collaborating with them.
And I'm sure a learning
process for them.
And I will say that one of
the good things about working
with somebody who
has no education
in that particular
field, and just has feel
is that I make mistakes that
are interesting sometimes.
I make mistakes that
are horrible sometimes.
But I also make mistakes
that are interesting.
And that might make
sense here at Google.
I don't know how they tell
you to be in the culture.
SPEAKER 2: Fail fast.
DAVID DUCHOVNY: Fail fast?
SPEAKER 2: That's
what they tell us.
DAVID DUCHOVNY: I don't
understand what that means.
It means if you're on a bad
road, get off it quickly?
SPEAKER 2: Yeah, I guess,
like, make mistakes.
But learn from them fast.
DAVID DUCHOVNY: Oh.
I used to always quote
this Beckett thing, which
was fail again, fail better.
I wonder if it's been
ripped off by you guys.
Fail fast?
All right.
Fail fast.
I'm going to ponder on that.
SPEAKER 2: Yeah, so related to
that a little birdie told me,
or some publication I read,
that you didn't pick up
a guitar until, like--
you didn't learn guitar
until three years
or so before "Hell
or Highwater."
DAVID DUCHOVNY: Yeah.
SPEAKER 2: Is there
a reason why--
like first of all,
I guess, do you
regret picking it up so late?
DAVID DUCHOVNY: Yeah.
SPEAKER 2: And
was there a reason
why you chose to self-learn
versus get a teacher,
or you know, when you obviously
have the resources, right?
[LAUGHTER]
DAVID DUCHOVNY: That's funny.
BRAD DAVIDSON: David,
we just got a check
and we can afford
guitar lessons.
[LAUGHTER]
DAVID DUCHOVNY: You guys
want to take it over?
Well, you know, it's
a good question,
because I actually
have an answer for it.
Which is, I didn't
want any homework.
I mean, I didn't want
it to feel like I
was doing it for anybody.
I just wanted to teach myself
the chords and the songs
that I wanted to play on my
own, in my room, by myself.
And nobody ever
asked me to sing.
As you know, that
first song was rough.
I have trouble, you know, I
mean, it's, like, my pitch
is learned.
So nobody ever said, you know,
David's got to be in the choir,
because we got to
hear that boy sing.
So there I am--
there I am, learning
my chords and singing
as best I can in my room.
And the last thing I
wanted was to have to--
all my life, I've been doing
homework, as you referenced.
I've been in school.
When I act, I got
to learn lines.
I got to show up prepared.
I have homework every day.
I didn't want homework.
I didn't want
somebody to have to--
you did not practice, David.
You did not do your scales.
So I just wanted it to be fun,
without any kind of pressure.
So this is the only time
in my life it's ever been.
Everything I've ever done was
for somebody else's appraisal.
So it makes no sense
that I would actually
bring out this music for
other people's appraisal
at this point.
But that's where I'm at.
SPEAKER 2: So you
want to keep it
as your own thing,
right, just you?
DAVID DUCHOVNY: Well, no,
obviously not, obviously not.
I bring it out, you know.
At some point, I started to
feel like it was worthwhile
and it was good.
And I wanted to share it.
So that guy who just
spoke, Brad Davidson,
he was really pushing
me to get better.
And so the songs are worthwhile.
And so it was just me
being pushed, eventually.
And then it's just ironic that
something that started out just
for me ends up being
something that I do in public.
SPEAKER 2: I think in
the Cambridge sort of--
DAVID DUCHOVNY: It's
just I can never
get all those guys to come to
my house with all their stuff
and set up in my living room.
So I got to do it out here.
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKER 2: I think in the
Cambridge performance--
so David also performed
in our Cambridge office--
DAVID DUCHOVNY: Oh,
that's right, yeah.
SPEAKER 2: --you were joking
that people used to tell you,
like, don't sing.
Like, know they told you
you weren't a singer.
And then you got
a voice teacher.
DAVID DUCHOVNY: Yeah.
SPEAKER 2: And that
sort of reminded me
of the age old question
of talent versus grit.
DAVID DUCHOVNY: Yeah.
SPEAKER 2: And I wanted to
get your thoughts on that.
Like, you're obviously
a great singer now.
DAVID DUCHOVNY: No.
No.
But I have a voice, you know,
and I get up there and I sing.
I'll make mistakes.
You know, I'm pitchy, like
they say on "American Idol."
You know, pitchy?
But grit versus talent--
I think grit is a
talent, you know.
I played a lot of
sports in my life.
And I've seen guys with
tons of talent, but no grit.
And you kind of tend to blame
people with no grit in a way
that you wouldn't blame
somebody with no talent.
You know?
And I really do believe
that grit is a talent.
I don't know if it's
learned or if it's genetic.
But it's one thing I've tried
to teach my kids is resiliency,
I guess, is another word for it.
It's the ability to keep
at something when you suck.
And that was one of the
reasons why I took up guitar,
aside from wanting to
please myself in my room,
was I had young kids.
And I was adamant that
I would find something
that I didn't know how to do.
And I wanted them
to be musicians.
Not for their job,
but I just wanted
them to have that
opportunity in their lives.
And I thought, well, you know,
I'm always preaching at them
that you got to keep working.
So I'm going to show
them I'm going to work.
I'll try to get better at this
thing that I'm not good at.
And you know, lucky me,
they both play guitar.
My son is actually a really good
guitar player at this point,
so way better than me.
So when you start young,
there's a real advantage.
SPEAKER 2: Do you
guys jam together?
DAVID DUCHOVNY: You
know, if I sneak in.
Like, he doesn't want me there.
But you know, but if I
sneak in with a guitar,
you know, if he's playing.
But he plays-- he loves the
music that I grew up with.
He listens to late
'60s, '70s tunes.
He's playing "Wish You
Were Here" by Pink Floyd.
And he's in a time
warp that I love,
and I hope he never gets out.
SPEAKER 2: So in this--
DAVID DUCHOVNY: So I'm a
big fan of grit, I guess.
I'm a big fan of talent as well.
But--
SPEAKER 2: It's a thesis, grit.
DAVID DUCHOVNY: I'm
all about the grit.
SPEAKER 2: OK.
So I guess in this album,
I know one of the songs,
"Jericho," is a song kind
of written to your father.
Do you any songs
that you particularly
hold close to your heart?
Or you're kind of agnostic?
DAVID DUCHOVNY: Well, I'm
agnostic with a yearning
for something greater, sure.
I think we all have to be
joined with something greater
than ourselves or our egos.
But I think all the songs--
I was thinking, like,
oh, I'm at Google.
I'm going to say
something really clever.
That all the songs
are, like, and I don't
know what writing code is.
But all the songs are
like writing code.
[LAUGHTER]
Language is like writing code.
I don't know what
writing code is.
Let me just emphasize that.
But language is a code.
We think of language
as something
that's opaque and
transparent to our thoughts.
But it's not.
It's an actual code, and it's
slippery, and it's inexact.
And so when I write
songs, I love that fact.
When I speak, I
don't love that fact.
When I try and make
my heart clear,
my mind clear to somebody,
then it's frustrating
because words are
always inadequate.
But in a song, it can get
much bigger than, you know--
you're writing about
something, but it's
coding for something else.
It's not what code means.
I know-- so forgive me.
But I just had that
thought coming over here.
But what was the question?
"Jericho" is about
my father, coded.
Yeah.
A lot of my songs-- like,
"Half-life" is-- the code is,
you could say, it's divorce.
You could say it's midlife.
You know, there's many
different ways into that song.
And I deliberately am
vague, specifically
vague enough to make
it both personal to me
and hopefully universal
to other folks.
SPEAKER 2: So it's
like any artist.
You leave it up to
the interpreter.
You put it out there, and then--
DAVID DUCHOVNY: Well, yeah,
I mean, I think any song--
I mean, I could sit you down and
I can walk you through a song
and tell you what I
thought I was writing.
And that will be
interesting if you said,
well, actually, I thought
that song was about this.
And hopefully,
your interpretation
wouldn't be about,
well, something
happened in David's life and
he did this and he did that,
but it would be,
like, to your life.
So yes, there's something--
especially, less
about movies,
television, and novels,
and more about
music, which to me
is very much you give
that to other people
and you let them kind of
make it their own for them.
You know?
This song now belongs
to you, and you
make it mean what you want.
I think, more than
the other art forms,
songs are really like that.
SPEAKER 2: So before I ask
this final question of you,
if anyone in the audience
has Q&A questions,
you can start lining up in the
two microphones on the side
now.
No one's getting up.
OK.
DAVID DUCHOVNY: Wow.
SPEAKER 2: So I think a
lot of us who work here--
DAVID DUCHOVNY: The
band, any of you guys
want to ask me anything?
SPEAKER 2: So a lot of us who--
I think people in general
strive to keep improving, right?
And like you put out an album,
and now you have a second one.
You have three books--
or sorry, you have
two books out now.
You have one forthcoming,
"Miss Subways."
DAVID DUCHOVNY: A third.
SPEAKER 2: Oh, sorry, a
third one coming out in May,
"Miss Subways."
How do you approach your work
and just continuing to improve?
DAVID DUCHOVNY: I think
you just improve by doing.
You know, I think that's how
I learned how to be an actor.
I mean, I was lucky
enough to get a job.
I started fairly late for
it, I thought, 27, 27-ish.
I had gone to graduate
school, as you mentioned.
SPEAKER 2: It was a
summer job, right?
DAVID DUCHOVNY: Yeah.
And it turned into that, yeah.
So I really was lucky in that
one of the first jobs I got was
the "X-Files, " and I got to
go to work every day for, like,
14 hours a day, being an actor.
And after a couple of
years of that, I learned.
But I didn't know.
I thought I knew.
I guess what's blissful is
that if you think you're better
than you are in the beginning.
I don't know how you can
teach that to somebody.
But it's, like,
have more confidence
than you should have.
And then you go forward
and you try things.
And then, eventually, as
you get actual experience,
you realize, oh, no, you
actually sucked back then.
But that time has passed,
and now you're OK, actually.
So you don't have to
worry about it so much.
Unless it's my case,
when it plays in reruns,
and you get to watch
how bad it was.
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKER 2: All right.
We're going to
open up for Q&A. I
guess we'll start here because
there's more people there.
AUDIENCE: Hey,
David, how are you?
I'm Sarah.
DAVID DUCHOVNY: Hi, Sarah.
AUDIENCE: Hey.
So you're clearly a
multi-talented artist,
as we saw you perform today.
Curious to know which
musicians, dead or alive,
have inspired you to make your
music or any favorite songs you
have.
DAVID DUCHOVNY:
Well, I mean, it's--
to say that I'm
inspired would be
to say that I could
actually, you know,
do something in the
vein of them on purpose.
I can't do that.
I'm more of an
unconscious songwriter,
because like I said, I'm
not schooled in that way.
So if I tried to write a
Beatles song, I couldn't do it.
But certainly I feel
inspired by the Beatles,
or Petty or Bowie or you know,
Sly and the Family Stone.
And I do want to get a little
more funky in my music,
you know?
I want a little more--
AUDIENCE: George Clinton-esque?
DAVID DUCHOVNY: Who?
George Clinton?
That's a little too funky.
AUDIENCE: That's,
like, super funk.
[LAUGHTER]
DAVID DUCHOVNY: Atomic Dog,
yeah, something like that.
I mean, really Sly and
the Family Stone, for me--
even like '70s, like
The Ohio Players,
you know, stuff like that.
But I don't even know.
We got to talk about
doing shit like that.
We're ready.
Yeah, we're ready.
Fleetwood Mac is another
band that I really
like the sound of.
You know, The Stones I
love, but I don't know
how I'm influenced by them.
But you know.
AUDIENCE: You definitely
have a Petty sound.
So keep it going.
DAVID DUCHOVNY: Ah, Petty, yeah.
Yeah, Petty, Petty, Wilco.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
I'm also a native New Yorker.
I appreciate what you said
about loving it and wanting
to leave it.
I'm actually leaving
to move to LA,
and I was wondering if you could
give any advice to a New Yorker
moving to LA on what to do.
[LAUGHTER]
DAVID DUCHOVNY: Sunscreen?
I love LA.
I got to say.
And I think people
want to leave LA, too.
I don't know.
Where are you going
to move in LA?
You don't know?
You don't know where?
AUDIENCE: I'm not sure,
maybe Santa Monica.
DAVID DUCHOVNY: Oh, yeah, sure.
Why not?
Yeah, no, you've got--
you're fine, you know.
Santa Monica, I love
Santa Monica, Venice.
I love-- if you
come from New York,
you kind of want to
see the ocean, I feel.
And I always liked
to see the ocean.
So that's kind of
where I've lived in LA.
I feel like to see
the end of the world
at the edge of the world.
I see to see the
edge of the world.
[LAUGHTER]
I like seeing no more people.
Just fish.
AUDIENCE: Hi, David.
Thanks for coming.
My name's Tibby.
My question for you is
I think fans of yours,
we all know you for
your sense of humor.
And I think, even back
in the "X-Files" days,
we saw you inject humor
into what could otherwise be
a really dramatic character.
And then you kind of
finally got to explore that
in "Californication."
So my question is, was starting
out in such a serious character
in kind of a serious world, was
that kind of almost a struggle
to be able to show that side
of yourself or tap into it?
DAVID DUCHOVNY:
Well, it was more
a perceptual thing for others.
Because the character was so--
well, he was dry.
But you had to be
paying attention
if you wanted to think
Mulder was funny.
It was very easy to think
of him as not funny at all.
And it was important
for me, always,
to inject that, as you
say, into the show.
And it was always
something, even going back
to the last time we
did it this year.
The fight is always,
you know, me wanting
to make it funny and real.
And the studio saying,
but people are dead.
And to me, that was never a
good enough argument, you know?
To me, the funny is the
cold of it, you know.
So it was more--
but it was more,
when I was coming
off the show, people
didn't perceive me that way.
No, other people didn't
perceive me that way.
It's just-- I don't
look funny, I think.
I don't know.
I don't look like I'm going
to be funny or something.
So yeah, I had to struggle
with that a little.
And it was also finding
the right comedy for me.
And then when I got off the
"X-Files" the first time,
it was really the heyday
of, like, you know, Ben--
Ben Stiller, and even
going to Jim Carrey,
Steve Carell, Will Ferrell.
And this is a different
kind of comedy than I do.
And so I was kind of
forlorn about all that.
I was, like, you know, I
can't go against those guys
doing that stuff.
I was looking for more like
'70s style comedy in the movies.
So when I took
"Californication,"
it was really, like, oh,
that's kind of what I can do.
Articulate in that way,
and not like a manchild,
not like a boy.
Like a man in a man's
world, whatever, doing that
stuff-- so I thought
I could do that.
AUDIENCE: Definitely,
it was super hilarious.
DAVID DUCHOVNY: Yeah?
Thanks.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Hi, I'm Corey.
Thank you for coming in.
You've worked in a lot
of different mediums--
TV, film, music, writing.
And they all have
really different ways
of pulling in your
creative process.
Which do you really prefer?
What do you think reflects
your work as an artist--
collaborative work,
or kind of individual,
heads down in your
room alone work?
DAVID DUCHOVNY: Well, both--
I mean, I think the novels
represent my most selfish, just
me, in a room.
You know, I have an
editor, and he edits me.
But it's really just--
that's just coming from me.
That's not collaborative.
Music is very collaborative
with the band.
I need it.
Film and television
is, by nature,
extremely collaborative.
And I love that.
A good director hires--
is like a good
president-- hires people
who are better than he is
or she is at the things
that he or she doesn't do.
And we see what happens
when that doesn't happen.
[LAUGHTER]
Although it's almost
an impossibility
to think of somebody
who's not better
than our current president
at-- at anything.
And yet he finds people that are
less better at it than he is.
Interesting.
So that's what a director does.
So a director is like the
immune system of the film.
He keeps all the bad ideas out
and let's all his other people
play with their good ideas.
So I really enjoy--
I do like to
collaborate very much.
But there came a time when I
wanted to sit down and just
write in my own voice.
And that's what the novels
kind of represented.
SPEAKER 2: All right.
I'm sorry, guys.
We don't have time for
any more questions.
DAVID DUCHOVNY: Aw.
Yell it out.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
DAVID DUCHOVNY: Why male models?
SPEAKER 2: David, do you
and your band have a--
DAVID DUCHOVNY: I don't
remember which it was.
[LAUGHTER]
I can't remember which was
the hand that I modeled.
SPEAKER 2: Oh, yeah.
DAVID DUCHOVNY:
Left [INAUDIBLE]..
[LAUGHTER]
It was before this--
Bulova watch catalog.
SPEAKER 2: Do you and your band
have time for one more song?
DAVID DUCHOVNY: Yeah!
SPEAKER 2: Cool.
DAVID DUCHOVNY: You asked
if there was a song that
was meaningful to me.
So actually, the last song
that we're going to do also
involves my father.
It's called "Stranger
and the Sacred Heart."
And we were touring in
Europe, and we were in Paris.
And I went to this
church called The Sacred
Heart, which is in the
neighborhood of the hotel I
was staying at.
And I was told by the
folks there that people--
the custom there is
to pray for others,
not to pray for yourself.
And actually, to pray
for the world really,
not just Paris, not just French
people, but actually the world.
And I thought, I'd
never heard that before.
And I really liked it.
So the song, along with
the fact that my father had
died in Paris a few years
earlier, kind of came together.
It's called "Stranger
and the Sacred Heart."
[MUSIC - DAVID DUCHOVNY,
"STRANGER AND THE SACRED
HEART"]
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.